everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today are gonna be
going over one of the more satisfying
things in chess and that is having your
opponent fall for a chest trap we're
gonna be going over the top six chess
traps two main criteria that I'm using
for my list
the first one is ease of use if you have
a really intricate chess trap you're not
gonna see it that often that's not gonna
make my list the second one is just how
much fun it is to actually have your
opponent fall for this trap and at the
end of that coming up with a victory the
more fun the higher up on the list it's
going to be so without further ado let's
get into the top six chess traps
the first rap is the legal trap starts
out with E 4 E 5 met f3 knight c6 pretty
common Bishop to c4 pawn d6 solidifying
the pawn chain here Knight to c3 Bishop
coming down pinning down the Knights and
pawn h3 forcing the Bishop back the
Bishop really should be capturing here
but if they come back to h5 this is
where the legal trap can be deployed and
that is Knight takes on e5 says yeah if
you want to pin down my Knight to the
Queen I don't really care because if you
take my queen that's gonna end up in
checkmate no way for black to stop this
Bishop comes here to f7 the King has
only one move this d7 square is
protected by the Knights King comes to
e7 and then Knight to d5 and this is
checkmate in a very fun and interesting
way your opponent's are not gonna see it
coming and that is the legal trap
coming at number five on our list is the
Blackburn shilling gambit trap and it
starts out similar to the legal trap of
e45 and then f3 knight c6 Bishop to c4
but now black can play Knight to the
four now this is setting up a trap that
says yeah go ahead and take my material
here on e5 if they do take that material
the Queen can come to g5 now a couple
things could happen if they are really
scared about this pawn on g2 they could
play something like g3 this nights going
to fall if they see that the Knights
under attack they could come down to f7
this Bishop is protecting the night so
they could feel that this is a safe
Square but unfortunately for them it is
not the Queen can now come to g2
attacking at this rook now if they want
to hold on to this rook they may play
rook to f1 but that's gonna lose to
Queen to e4 check and there's no real
way to stop this if they want to give up
their queen that's fine then I can come
in here if they want to stop it with
their Bishop then the sneaky
checkmate of Knight to f3 Bishop can't
take care it's being pinned down there
the Queen you have a really nice
checkmate now if we come back and we say
maybe they don't want to move their rook
over here to f1 they could decide to
capture more material they may not see
the threat that black has here but then
Queen takes on h1 Bishop to f1 that's
the only option that white has Queen to
e4 check same thing as before we see
that the Queen's gonna fall here on e2
if they play the Bishop to e2 then
Bishop c5 and this is going to end up in
a checkmate there's no way for white to
stop this I'll give you the quick
version here if you haven't seen this
position before Knight to c3 Knight to
f3 check as we've seen before it's not
mate though because the King can come
over here to f1 but now Queen to h4 and
this is the threat right here
Queen coming to f2 this would be a
checkmate really forced to come over
here but there's gonna be a checkmate
pretty soon after that
you
coming at number four on our list is the
elephant trap starts out with a d4 d5 c4
the Queens gambit line c6 gonna decline
that line Knight to c3 Knight f6 and
then Bishop to g5 pinning down the
knight to this Queen here Knight to d7
as a continuation defending this and
then after the pond takes which is
fairly common from white the pawn can
recapture now white may have a sense
that he can just come in and take this
pond
since the Knights blocking this Queen
here he may say I can't recapture with
this Knight that Bishop is pinning down
the knight to the Queen that's exactly
what we want white to think because
after he takes here on d5 but I can take
the knight doesn't even matter that the
Queen is exposed here if the bishop
comes down and takes here on a d8 that's
going to be completely fine Bishop plays
appear to be for the only legal move
that white has is to play Queen to d2
after the bishop takes the king is going
to recapture and the King takes here on
d8 black is up a good amount of material
here so that is the elephant trap
coming at number three on our list is
the Lasker trap starts out with d4 d5 c4
the Queens gambit line and then II 5
this is the Alban counter game but if
you don't play much Alban counter game
it you should rethink two decisions in
your life but in this trap we're gonna
see the pond take on e5 which is pretty
common
and then black pushing forward with the
four it is defended by the Queen here
can always gobble up this material later
and you may see white play III now this
is a mistake here but he may say hey
yeah if you want to go ahead and take
your all exchange my Queen down here I
have a good center control here flex
instead of taking going to play his
Bishop to a b4 check and pretty common
to see the bishop come to d2 and now we
continue along with our trap and that is
the pond taking here on e3 now they
could think that yeah I'll go ahead and
take your Bishop right here this is a
mistake by black because then you're
gonna play your queen down here the
kings in a recapture doesn't matter if
you take with your pawn right here why
it's gonna be up in material
unfortunately for white like has other
things up his sleeves and if he does
take with his Bishop here on b4 then the
pawns gonna take here on f2 this is
check the King comes to e 2 and now the
critical move and that is the pawn takes
here on g1 can turn into any piece it
wants to it's gonna turn into a knight
check and a couple things gonna happen
either a the King is gonna move away
from the Queen and the Queen is going to
fall or if the King comes back here to
e1 Queen comes to h4 check King to d2
not in the best spot and then Knight to
c6 while there's not an immediate
checkmate black has so many different
options to attack his opponent not every
day you can say that you have three
nights on the board as well that's a fun
check mark that you get to put off your
list of chess accomplishments all and of
itself so if nothing else getting three
nights for the Lasker trap having your
opponent fall in and then just change
his King around the rest of the game
gets its place to number three on the
list
coming number two on our list is the
England gambit trap starts out with d4
d5 yes this is a real opening and if you
haven't played it definitely recommend
it pawn takes here Knight c3 attacking
the pawn why usually tries to hold on to
the material Bishop to e7 if they
continue with Bishop to f4 to hold on
this material then we're gonna play
Queen to b4 this is check also attacking
the bishop here on f4 they're usually
gonna bring their Bishop back here
attack the Queen Queen's gonna come take
on b2 and then the failed move from
White's standpoint is Bishop c3 feels
like it's good attacking the Queen can't
take the rook here on a1 it's defended
by the knight on b1 but unfortunately
it's gonna fail to Bishop to b4 it's
just no real good way for white to
continue if he tries to block off with
this Queen here could just take with
this Bishop Queen takes sure Queens even
come up here that is going to be
checkmate if instead takes with his
knight here sure go ahead and take the
rook here on a one night comes back
could see an exchange in the center of
the board Black is just hey free rook
right here so it does have some options
if instead of the Queen coming here
could just take with the Bishop here
Knight takes on at b4 and there's just
no real good way for white to continue
wants to hold on to the rook here on a1
but if he plays Knight to c3 well that's
gonna fail just just the Queen takes
here if instead he brings his knight to
a3 as well it's trying to open up for
the Queen to protect this that's also
going to fail as well so no real way to
hold on to this so really while he
thinks that the bishop coming here to
see three is gonna met him a good
position here in the center of the board
unfortunately that is the trap we are
laying very easy for them to fall into
very easy for us to execute that is the
England gambit trap coming in at number
two
coming at number one on the list is the
fishing pole trap two main reasons I
have a number one the first one is you
just have so many opportunities to play
it it derives from the Rye Lopez you're
gonna play Knight to f6 they cast on the
kingside and then you play the very odd
move Knight to g4 second reason I like
is once you actually get this to land
it's just one of the more satisfying
things you'll ever play in chess they
will usually play h3 you're trying to
kick your knight back off and you play
h5 says I do not care what you're doing
go ahead and take my knight that's fine
if they do this you attack the knight
Knight comes back to E 1 and then Queen
h4 and there's no way to stop mates from
here you're threatening the Queen coming
up here to h1 or h2 if they try to open
up for their King to move on this f2
pawn or f2 square doesn't really matter
you just play g3 and then there's gonna
be a mate followed shortly thereafter
even if they don't play E 1 you still
have a lot of attacking opportunities
you're gonna have an extremely good game
but so satisfying they play back to e1
thinking they're in a good spot and then
you come play Queen h4 and they just
realized that the game is over very very
shortly so those are my six top chess
traps there are a lot more chess traps
on my website I'll have a link below if
you're watching this on youtube there
are a ton of chess traps these are just
my favorite top six would love to hear
from y'all what's your favorite chest
trap is if you have one that you have
actually had someone fall into would
love to know that as well but thank you
guys so much for watching
definitely make sure you check out the
link below if you want to check out more
chess traps I'll see you guys in the
next video